did you know that Drew Barrymore called
the actual police to the screen set or
that there's hidden sound bites for
movies like X and like what about the
fact that there was supposed to be an
entire Trilogy based around Emma
Robert's character Jill well don't worry
I did all the research so you didn't
have to Jason Takes Manhattan is the
eighth installment of the Friday the
13th franchise and one of my absolute
favorites in the series a maniac trying
to kill us Welcome to New York did you
notice that our first ghost face in
screen six Jason was watching it on TV
before the real ghost face calls him up
unfortunately for him that's going to be
the last movie he'll ever see not a bad
choice though truly in the horror genre
a trip to New York City was not an
uncommon plot we got a list of movies
from Paramount that they owned that we
could use in the movie this is scream's
way of giving us a little nod to the
infamous Friday the 13th installment
that brought some of the most iconic
executions and the second we saw that
one we were like oh there it is
place so who else thought Sarah Michelle
Geller's character CeCe was offed too
soon
also fun fact she shot Scream 2 before
Buffy the Vampire Slayer season two and
because Wes Craven wanted her to cut her
hair for scream her new haircut was
actually written into Buffy anyway I
digress when Tara almost goes upstairs
with Frankie at the Frat party he
innocently asks her if she's part of the
Omega beta Zeta sorority
it was a nice moment that kind of
brought our girl CC back for a minute
but did you catch that when you first
watched it being so into her chosen
character Drew Barrymore accidentally
called the police to set during filming
when she was filming her opening scene
the phone she was using was actually
connected to a landline so during one of
her takes she legit dialed 9-1-1 by
accident and ended up hanging up but
unfortunately the police came to set
Sirens blaring ready to try and help
Casey make it past the first 15 minutes
of the movie Never call 9-1-1 and hang
up they gotta answer that now please
leave a comment if you caught this I'd
be majorly impressed in one of scream
6's more subtle Easter eggs Liza sound
cue from the incredible movie X written
and directed by Ty West and also
starring Jenna Ortega when you hear a
knock at the door of Samantha's
therapist that's actually the sound cue
from the movie X it's actually a cool
little nod from the directors as they're
both friends with tie West because they
all work together on the horror movie
VHS from 2012. it really is a small
world in the horror genre so this
shouldn't come as a total shock as
directors love to make little cameos in
their films even Wes Craven showed up in
the first Scream movie The Scream 6
directors Matt battinelli open and Tyler
Gillett show up in the movie wearing
Halloween costumes Matt's dressed up as
Kurt Cobain and Tyler has a fake knife
stuck in his head my friends who else's
favorite Ghostface was scream 4's Jill
what world are you living in I don't
need friends did you know that it was
going to be the start of another Trilogy
when Wes Craven started talking to the
writer Kevin Williamson about going back
to Woodsboro he didn't want it to just
be for a one-off he wanted to do a whole
new ghost face Trilogy with Emma Roberts
in the original Scream 4 Jill's fate was
supposed to be left uncertain with the
Cliffhanger to be resolved in the next
installment unfortunately though Wes
Craven passed away in 2015 and Kevin
Williamson didn't want to create an
entire Trilogy without him did you
notice this callback in Scream 5 when
Sam is on the phone with Ghostface she
in a fit of rage demands for him to come
and get her come and get me with
pleasure Sydney Prescott has that exact
experience with her ghost face in Scream
too she also demands the killer to come
and get her then why don't you show your
face you coward to which Ghost Face
responds my pleasure we almost didn't
get him on the series at all he actually
turned down the screen project not once
but twice in the 90s Wes Craven was
known for his horror genre movies
because of a Nightmare on Elm Street and
The Hills Have Eyes so obviously he was
a Top Choice for the director when
scream was being considered for
production among other names like
Quentin Tarantino at that time though
Wes Craven wanted to take a break from
all things Gore so he ended up turning
the project down because he thought it
was way too violent and like obviously
though after rejecting the movie twice
he did end up coming around how do you
think the series would have turned out
without him so I already mentioned how
Wes Craven made an appearance in the
first film he showed up as the janitor
Fred obviously wearing a Freddy Krueger
sweater because well duh there's also a
direct reference to The Nightmare on Elm
Street movies more so how the sequels
all sucked and aside from this there are
a ton of other Wes Craven references
scattered throughout the film even in
Scream 6 you can spot hundreds of Wes
Craven costumes in the first film Tatum
mentions Wes Carpenter movies which is a
combination of Wes Craven and John
Carpenter starting to sound like some
West Carpenter flickers the director of
the 1978 Halloween movie there's also a
Freddy Krueger sweater hanging on the
door and scream too a poster for The
Hills Have Eyes and a trivia question
about Freddy in Scream 4. Freddy Krueger
uh raise your hand like I could go on
but this video would be hours long so
what are some other Wes Craven
references you picked up on it wasn't
until Kevin Williamson met the writers
and directors for Scream 5 that he felt
comfortable continuing the project they
even paid a heartfelt tribute to Wes
Craven on screen Dylan Minnette plays
the character Wes Hicks and in Scream 5
in which they describe his brutal end as
the ultimate tribute for Wes Craven it's
holy drawn out and filled with red
herrings all the way until his gory
demise in the film students host a
memorial for Wes which doubles as an
on-screen memorial for Wes Craven when
the kids toast to West
the voices of all the cast and crew from
the previous movies were layered in as a
way for them to pay tribute to the
iconic director also known as our
favorite Leading Lady Drew Barrymore did
you know that she was actually supposed
to play Sidney Prescott but she chose to
play Casey Instead at the time having
your biggest star and face of the film
offed within the first 15 minutes was
absolutely unheard of well we can thank
Drew Barrymore for that shocking twist
she talked about this decision with Sean
Evans in 2020. in the horror film genre
my biggest pet peeve was that I always
knew the main character was going to be
slugging through at the end but was
going to Creak by and make it what I
wanted to do is take that comfort zone
away so I asked if I could be Casey
Becker so that we would establish that
the rule does not apply in this film did
you know Ghostface Works two jobs it's
funny because Courtney Cox is often
pointed out to be the only character who
has been with the entire franchise since
the very beginning but that's not true
Roger L Jackson the voice of Ghostface
has also been with the franchise since
the very beginning
I like that thing you're doing with your
voice Randy this whole time I thought it
was an actual voice changer correct
Amber might live to see the sunrise nope
it's just one talented guy can you
handle that
Monday something else that's pretty
hilarious too is that he also does the
voice of Mojo Jojo from The Powerpuff
Girls Do not continue with the ramblings
for my ramblings other ramblings will be
it's so clear why they did this
Halloween Trope there are so many
references within all of the costumes
more than I could ever possibly list on
this one video as a nod to Roger there's
one person dressed as Mojo Jojo in the
subway station oh come on now so I could
go on and on about the scream world and
all its clever references and Easter
eggs hidden in each scene but I'll spare
you my ramblings just this once we share
a certain history what's your favorite
Easter egg and what do you think should
have been included in the list
foreign